Oh God oh [ __ ] I got the weed out of
Ferris Moke when she dumped that [ __ ]
get it gonna insane so if you wanna dump
somebody smoke this weed
oh [ __ ] it's nonstop oh [ __ ] Lee oh
there you go damn on the beach oh [ __ ]
you play this baggie
we're gonna empty this [ __ ]
before the nights over don't stop you
want to go to blue Corral for the
endless buffet this is the Voodoo Lounge
the end this stop afraid who said bong
hit oh [ __ ] you're in for a good night
oh [ __ ] look at 10 mm off the bat we're
gonna go for another four five
throughout the show tonight raise our
resistance we've been slipping some
people I don't want to mention no names
and no names no names
[Music]
I don't forget as usual whatever drug
you're doing hydrate young-sam even when
I was doing blow I always had a bottle
of water close by wasn't the healthiest
water what the [ __ ]
Jim Sam Flint this Flint [ __ ] who said
bonk it oh [ __ ] you're in for a good
night we got some apple [ __ ] fritters
here we go
oh [ __ ] named them today
oh [ __ ]
one down I got about 19 canisters a week
understand me
I'm dipping into my [ __ ] reserve now
[Music]
yeah sure I check a ball of [ __ ]
tequila you don't leave canister two
canisters condoms as condoms you don't
leave everything out anything
you drank tequila that [ __ ] some good
[ __ ] tequila as a matter of fact it's
Monday we got a little toast for the
spirits actally does his bong hit of
death here we're going in deep tonight
concept as you understand me there's
there no more [ __ ] around time of the
year all this is your last time to [ __ ]
around cuz September's come you know
what that means
you're 120 days away from the [ __ ]
holidays let me ask you a question
you've been broke during the holidays
death too dude close to killing yourself
yet if we don't get off your ass you're
gonna be there again this year concept
sitting there people's houses like a
[ __ ] what month L'Orange you know I'm
saying go out there get a job it's the
last quarter do something let the
government know you're alive and kicking
justify your existence I don't give a
[ __ ] let's do this [ __ ] Lee look at this
guy tip-top Magoo he looks good you got
no suntan you spot-free per minute for a
minute there we go
there's tremendous blend right here a
couple Reapers hold on don't run away
there you go shut that in like a soldier
all the way suck that bucket there you
go all the way don't blow it now will
you blow down the Illinois all the way
there you go want to watch you
understand me I [ __ ] around no more I
got some weed delivered on Sunday to the
house a [ __ ] the armored car dropped
it off yeah listen when an armored car
drops off a bag of weed at your house
you don't ask no questions you sign your
going side I got a shop tequila for you
walk talk in the name of love oh [ __ ]
before you break my heart
ah your bad [ __ ] Monday night
August 7th will you think you're dealing
with that
here we go [ __ ]
[Music]
I'm not no Limburger why don't you dance
with me
maybe my left nut smells look Lindbergh
you from time to time we people don't
know what Limburger it's a cheese that
smells like 10 dead [ __ ] I don't know
why say if people are sensitive young
say why don't you dance with me I ain't
no limbo
are you [ __ ] nuts where's that quail
we had hidden in here from the 80s
we got a quaint loot we had a terminal
we got everything we got an off eBay or
some little Japanese guy with no ears
[ __ ] them anyway leave what's going on
with the Stars
because I saw pyjamas profile had no
ears you have to [ __ ] sign language
is up let's eat that [ __ ] star Lee
they say no uh don't that yes
what the [ __ ] won't we'll do a different
one now this is I'm telling you I got
some people listen it's the harvest
right now but two people broke up this
[ __ ] they had saved in the vault
I got some [ __ ] at the house now you
hear the national anthem all day all day
sunday as the national anthem all
[ __ ] day every ten minutes I was just
saluting feet Boy Scouts librarians you
know what are you gonna do that's what
we do here no drugs
a little reefer a little water maybe a
couple edibles we're back star number
one always doing its thing I promise you
will be Wil Wheaton this bag that I will
get in close leaves to get your [ __ ]
son
because we got sick they're doing people
is she the same don't start Museum I'm
saying you've seen a little Mexican kids
on the store on the corners of maps
[ __ ] Joey's Buddha lounge go see
stars know what Starkiller's he
understand star killers there we go oh
[ __ ] I don't know what you doing break
up the leotards let's do this [ __ ]
[ __ ] Monday night leaves over
there thinking about his future he well
he's like Greg glassy he walked into
Burger King
just to snoop around for a minute yeah
I'm saying if you don't watch the guest
book on Thursday unfriendly [ __ ]
unfriendly [ __ ] this Thursday
PBS seven o'clock Pacific ten o'clock
Eastern Time tape both episodes I'm
gonna go to your [ __ ] house listen
I'll tell you what whoever tapes the
episode and tweets me with the [ __ ]
episode on next time I come to your city
you're gonna find something on the floor
by mistake understand me and you know
uncle Joey don't [ __ ] around I always
leave something you better leave
something for the mouse you know me you
come over able to find the weed I know
you're looking to make a dollar we gotta
leave something for the mouse cuz if you
don't leave something for the mouse then
you can't come back here dance this mess
around
who said bond it and if you have a team
you little [ __ ] I find out you're
watching this [ __ ] and I'm gonna come to
your [ __ ] house anyway
these little young vegetarians when I
don't go Joey
they don't want to eat me and either
storm will eat the captains their
intestine system goes into [ __ ]
banana here we go
oh listen if anybody yet listen if you
don't transcend if you know a [ __ ]
they got strong pills go to their house
right now and [ __ ] overnight me one
of those [ __ ] valium Jimmy the [ __ ]
value you go to the doctor you tell me
hearing voices they give you like a
point to five that don't do dick to dick
give a little [ __ ] say give me a xanax
it looks like a bar of gold think that
is [ __ ] big big in those thousand
loading ramp [ __ ] pumpkin valiums I'm
saying you've been there now all right
what you people hang out with [ __ ]
what types of Christians are you anyway
here we go
please ready for a bong hit I'm ready
for a bonnet it's a good night for a
bumpy right or wrong and my lion teeth
do you think like am i coming on too
strong it's not like I asked the thingy
if I came to your house and said let me
finish
that's [ __ ] one thing I don't want a
finger nobody I'm just saying is it to
eat I'm saying is it too much the
[ __ ] ass the door bumpy I don't I
don't leave much I need a bonnet chicken
cutlets my wife by the way I want to
give a shout out cherry Diez made
chicken cordon bleu from scratch tonight
old-school with extra Swiss and that
[ __ ] had two piece of chicken
cordon bleu with a big [ __ ] salad I'm
ready to go when I [ __ ] that chicken out
it's gonna be all over a big shout-out
to my wife I love my one big shout out
chicken cordon how did you know she was
doing I got to the kitchen I saw a piece
of Swiss cheese I thought she was making
a killer sandwiches
there's no Cuban food rule in my house
yeah you ain't Cuban don't cook
beautiful do me a favor
no buzzing we cooked a meal in honor of
you leave the [ __ ] alone
stick to what you know cheeseburgers
[ __ ] uh grilled cheese macaroni and
cheese don't show up Nancy get down and
tell me you made a Cuban meal for me cuz
I've run out of your house like a
chihuahua cheese I'm saying all you'll
see is a little [ __ ] flame of light
flying through ya rock rock rock rock
lobster here we go
[Music]
this is the mild [ __ ] here
this was Zombo right here this is called
apple fritters perennial on Ventura tell
him uncle Joey's saying you know give
you something alright
they always take care of people don't
eat the right number label the other
match master mix I got here this [ __ ] is
grown what here we go now this [ __ ] is
grown at a better value understand me so
you take two birds with one stone
your little service dog people will get
on the planes [ __ ] you smoke a bong head
of this you'll kick that dog and you'll
be free cuz I'm saying don't wanna pick
it up dog [ __ ] no more walking around
like a little bag a little bug [ __ ] [ __ ]
those days are over
[Music]
rock lobster this is nice this is nice
ateva
you like this hold on to that okay King
I take care of my peopie him the best
quality overall [ __ ] reefer and drugs
available you understand me even when I
was doing coke can eat Gorilla Biscuits
I just didn't buy off anybody
I bought this [ __ ] that [ __ ] killed
Len Bias you understand
34:30 tuesday night 8 o'clock what's the
bonded position well now let's go open
when you bend your head remember not to
close the throat you're bending your
body you don't want to bend your head
like you know like you [ __ ] church
like a [ __ ]
because then you close off the esophagus
your [ __ ] always neck up when you do the
bonnet the little clowns like your
grandpa you know you'll see fat people I
got that that cortisone ball on their
neck and [ __ ] two more days they ringing
bells part-time anyway here we go down
down right bend the neck but don't bet
don't close the esophagus you want to
get the full effect of the THC right
what happens is you bend your neck and
also the smoke starts going coming out
of the ears right and your eyeballs I
said you [ __ ] you so far I got you
lobster Wow
my stay right there is the perfect way
right you gotta hit this bit the five
they go a little bull smoke suck that
[ __ ] all the way follow it there
you go
[Music]
boys in beginning girls and surfboards
everybody's walking everybody's grooving
what listen to this [ __ ] heroine
guitar right here this kid old deep
three years later there's a heroin
guitar hey Eddie put on your nose dog
what put on the lifeguard right here
that's the tanning butter I'm surfing
I'm surfing comes the stingray you beat
the bushes [ __ ] you're smacking her
in the ass and you beat the bushes and
you're [ __ ] breathing through your
nose
here we go cops up this
look out for that piranha dad goes look
at Li here we go I'm telling you 1979
b-52's first [ __ ] out go shoot
yourself in this damn it here we go ba
la stop rock lobster oh [ __ ]
rock lobster I'm telling your mother
[ __ ] we're going deep tonight into
the trenches
we got another bag of red stars we got
unlimited we for we got unlimited
resources you understand me we hang out
with our chapels nephew anyway
youtube.com slash c / Joey Diaz is the
place to be Jack what time you got that
booby booby that's a term of endearment
in the Jewish community 7:45 and all is
well [ __ ]
it could be 8:45 where you're at 9:45
10:45 if you're in London I got no
[ __ ] idea I'm too hard to be doing
man
anyway this [ __ ] Thursday so the
weekend sold out at the punchline
Thursday 10:15 listen that's a good show
that's when the stars kick in not on
snuff don't mention whatever else I got
my system mentally mentally I do all and
company every time I go to headset
somebody put something in my palm I'm
saying
[ __ ] MDMA [ __ ] windowpane next
week me and Leo definitely be doing a
[ __ ] acid podcast I already got the
call the guys showing up with
ultraviolet acid give me that [ __ ] me
neither but [ __ ] it take a chance
Columbus did you know I'm saying anyway
what else is crackalacking in your world
this is it we're doing this podcast you
get it Wednesday morning and I'm off to
[ __ ] San Francisco like a doctor
walking around those hills I'm gonna see
Denny poop the puss my girl Jenica
[ __ ] the artist of death up there
she's coming to the show with a
beautiful husband
we don't [ __ ] around he understand me
I'm auntie Dolores is coming oh yeah
she's May gonna come back I get
record dolores with down here win so
[ __ ] you but they got into the
[ __ ] cookie business for animals
flying matter it's a lot easier to deal
with animals do these [ __ ] humans I'm
saying so if your dog is walking with a
limp yep if your cats [ __ ] up it's got
bumps she's gonna send me a bunch of
[ __ ] for the cats and that's it and
that's that baby San Francisco this
weekend next weekend working out with
uncle Joey Pasadena again Saturday night
$15 and I'm saying you drop $15 on
[ __ ] cigarettes this [ __ ] we had a
great time last weekend where did we not
the master was there the brothel doing
15 my main man James you know me how we
switch up lineups but besides that
sitting that's that we're here [ __ ] I
don't work hard tomorrow I got a
non-stop day my day starts tomorrow at
9:00 a.m. I gotta go to hi doctor I
gotta come back over the hill I gotta go
a little swimmin with my daughter and
then what do I got I got a dinner with a
bunch of [ __ ] moose I gotta make
believe I [ __ ] like people any good
steak but [ __ ] you go you take the
hearbeat and you order dessert you get
one spoon in [ __ ] I'm gonna shed is
there with nobody anyway youtube.com
slash see that's the place to be yes its
last one youtube.com slash ceaseless
Joey Diaz that's the place to be this
reefer sensational should we do another
Bottomly how many stars a g8 nothing it
was back but back misses we're back
alright we ain't [ __ ] around no more
we took a couple days off tonight we're
taking it a bit those two stars because
that's the type of [ __ ] is you
understand me
were you gonna wave it upset for you
we're in America we two stars walk
around your point
anyway it's gonna be one of those nights
youtube.com slash c / Joey Diaz is the
place to be our guest tonight is Miss
Pat making a comeback tonight we'll talk
about her new book what's been going on
with her so strap on your [ __ ] seat
belt [ __ ] cuz we ain't [ __ ]
around tonight we're taking it back to
the old school we were slouching for a
while Joey Diaz went home put his
[ __ ] pieces together and now we're
back so listen break out your [ __ ]
notebooks you're about to learn
something laugh cry that's that's a
[ __ ] podcast anyway I'm [ __ ] up
ain't gonna like nobody understand me
remember to blow smoke up your ass and
tell ya this reefer got to me tonight
this is strong reefer perennial Ventura
stay black I love you don't forget SF
10:15 show myself and Dean del Rizzy